[Musique]
nous sommes tous Charlie près de 4
millions de França rassemblés en ce
dimanche pour dire non aux actes de
terrorisme commis par trois Français
musulmans se revendiquant pour deux
d'entre eux d'Al-Qaïda au Yémen et le
trisè de l'État islamique des attentats
per perpétrés contre des journalistes de
Charlie do mais également contre des
policiers et des citoyens de confession
juives et des rassemblements pour dire
oui à la liberté d'expression comment
les communautés religieuses réagissent
quel message est-il important
aujourd'hui de délivrer quelles actions
peuvent être menées par les différentes
communautés pour mieux informer et
éduquer les jeunes populations les
amalgames à ne pas commettre les
réalités à ne pas occulter pour en
parler ce soir avec nous Mohamed ou
kerobi bonsoir vous êtes le président
des musulmans de de Versailles savigour
bonsoir vous êtes le président du groupe
interreligieux pour la paix des ivelines
mendan nisanbum bonsoir vous êtes
président et Rabin de la communauté
juive de Montini le Bretonneux et
Abdelkarim Fars pardon bonsoir vous êtes
l'imam de la mosquée de de plaisir alors
d'abord je voudrais évidemment une
première réaction sur ces 4 millions de
de français mobilisés 2 millions et demi
rien qu' à Paris on a vu aussi qu'il y
avait énormément de de rassemblements
dans dans les illes on a vu 10000
personnes à Rambouillet 7000 à
Versailles 3000 à Montini le Bretonneux
vous étiez à Paris
dimanche vous avez t
Leem vous avez tous était avec la
communauté chrétienne de plaisir donc
c'était important de manifester à Paris
de de montrer l'ensemble que les
ensembles des communautés étaient
soudées avant de de dire que c'était
important il faut on voudrait
d'abord condamner hein c'est une
condamnation qui n'est jamais de trop
concernant pareil Act ensite nous avons
été bien naturellement affligé consterné
puis chacun c'est on est rentré dans une
sphère
d'incompréhension d'autant que la
communauté musulmane se sent
particulièrement visé et nous devons
déjouer tous les ces amalgam et donc le
musulman ne en réalité ne se justifie
pas mais c'est cette manifestation si on
peut le la confiner en un mot c'est elle
est l'expression d'un d'une bonne santé
de la France donc il y a des moments où
il faut se lever à l'unisson et dénoncer
de manière c'est-à-dire unie un acte
dénoncer pareil acte et pareil pratique
donc on est plutôt sur une logique de
dénonciation de
condamnation car le musulman se se voit
voler une partie de ce qui lui est cher
c'estàd sa religion et il la voit
amalgamer à ce que à ce que lui condamne
quels ont été justement les les premiers
mots que vous avez prononcé vous en tant
qu'imam parce que il y a aussi une
responsabilité en tant que effectivement
lors du sermon du dernier vendredi bah
le premier mot c'était condamnation à
dignation donc avant tout sans aucune
ambigué avec fermeté parce que ce genre
d'actes ne font pas partie de l'Islam ni
de la des valeurs enseigné par la
religion musulmane donc le premier
message qui a été passé lors du sermon
c'est la condamnation et l'indignation
par rapport à ce genre d'acte mais
également
euh
aussi montrer à travers les récits
coraniques les versets les la biographie
du Prophète qu'il a été le comportement
de de ce de de notre religion de notre
Prophète vis-à-vis de d'agression verbal
et même de ses pires ennemis pour
montrer que la religion musulmane c'est
une religion de paixigion de mis comment
comment comment réagit les les fidèles
musulmans quand vous le dites ce genre
de chos ils sont effectivement enfin
enfin la majorité des musulmans en fait
les actes qui ont été commis c'est le
0,001 % de la communauté la majorité des
musulmans en France ou ailleurs aspirent
à vivre en paix aspire à vivre le vivre
ensemble avec tout le monde enfin il y a
des gens enfin jeunes et moins jeunes
qui sont venus me voir enfin je dirais
même le témoignage d'un d'un parmix et
c'est un jeune il m a dit je voulais
venir te te t'embrasser la tête par
rapport au sermon qui avait été qui
avait été clair par rapport à la
position de l'Islam sur ce sujet-là h
euh je me tourne vers la communauté juif
comment ont réagit les fidèles quand ils
ont appris ce qui s'était passé à
l'épicerie cachère de Vincen alors bien
sûr avec beaucoup de douleur et beaucoup
d'inquiétude
mais tout en même temps aussi avec
beaucoup
d'unité et de dignité c'est-à-dire
malheureusement c'est un acte barbare
qui s'est passé
évidemment nous refusons l'amalgame
euh la communauté musulmane et la
communauté juive sentend extrêmement
bien
euh dans
l'histoire si on regarde l'histoire de
l'Islam l'histoire Juve c'est une
histoire qui se ressemble donc
on on cherche tous à la paix on cherche
tous à l'unité mais évidemment que des
actes ces actes barbares sont des actes
qui font qui font mal qui qui qui
inquiète énormément la communauté mais
nous savons nous savons qu'on nous
pouvons rester ici nous pouvons passer
ses acte et nous allons continuer notre
vie vous dites rester ici et pourtant on
entend dire que en 2014 la France est
devenue le premier pays source pour Laas
et l'immigration en Israël est-ce que
vous ou est-ce que des gens autour de
vous sont tentés de de repartir en
Israël parce qu'on se sent plus en tant
que juif protégé en franceors comme je
vous le disais en en effet il y a une
inquiétude une inquiétude globale qui
est là
euh des personnes qui m'appellent qui
viennent me voir des cors religionnaires
qui une inquiétude est-ce qu'on peut
encore sortir avec laakipa est-ce qu'on
peut se montrer juif se marquer juif ou
bien on risque éventuellement une une
certaine agression alors c'est vrai que
cette inquiétude existe est-ce que c'est
pour ça que N P pas nous pouvons pas
vivre en France euh non je
pour répondre à ma question je suis
français mes parents sont français mes
grands-parents aussi et nous avons
toujours vécu en France et je suis un un
de je suis un français de religion juive
et donc je resterai en France vous
resterai en France aujourd'hui sur le
territoire national on a recensé
plusieurs actes contre la communauté
musulmane vous avez effectivement tous
autour de cette table tout de suite
parler de ne pas faire l'amalgame mais
quand on on voit ces actes alors pas en
Île-deFrance et pas à Paris mais en tout
cas en province euh comment on réagit
parce que vous par exemple vous avez
demandé des mesures de sécurité
particulières je pense pour la mosquée
de plaisir ou ou à Versailles à versaill
on n' pas demandé de mesures de sécurité
particulière bien que la préfecture a a
dépêché un véhicule en en moment de
grande affluence un véhicule de police
bon de toute façon il y a des caméras
qui sont déjà disposé depuis un un long
moment
euh cela dit euh parce que il faut
aujourd'hui dans dans l'urgence au
moment au moment où la la France pas ce
moment de crise il faut savoir répondre
et être dans une dans la conjoncture de
d'une communication de dissuasion si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi à savoir que dans
cet élan de solidarité bien sûr c'est
une solidarité responsable qui doit
évoluer dans la sphère de de dissuasion
dissuader ce qui tentent de diviser les
Français donc cette cette dans cette
dans ce langage de communication bien
sûr il y a de la résistance et il faut
savoir être
responsable à ce niveau et permettre à
la France de de disons de de répondre à
ce genre de d'attitude en même temps il
faut savoir relativiser un peu tout cela
et faire en sorte que nous puissions
passer cette étape et nous prévir
surtout de de l'avenir donc ce que je
voulais dire par là il faut que dans le
comportement qui est le nôtre de que
qu'il s'agisse de la communauté
musulmane commité française dans sa
globalité il faudrait que il n'y ait pas
de défection or le but de ceux qui ont
perpétré cette attentat c'est justement
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
défections et comme je fais partie du
groupe interreligieux pour la paix donc
nous avons cette expérience qui nous
permet qui nous permet de revisiter
l'ensemble des religions de manière
différente donc une espèce de on va dire
une modélisation du de la relation à
l'autre qui nous permet de revisiter
donc l'événement avec le regard que l'on
que l'on a donc dans dans une
perspective de partage dans une logique
de partage et dans le but de servir au
mieux l'intérêt du pays donc il faut pas
perdre de vue ce qui est capital ce qui
est de ce qui est tout à fait secondaire
bon bien sûr qu'on s'attendait à ce
qu'il y ait des représables de ce genre
nous avons donné juste dans le cadre du
prêche puisque comme tu l'as dit du
vendredi nous avons reçu donc des des
personnalités Étienne pin était parmi
nous le le jour du Pr donc il il a
choisi de de se rendre à la mosquée il a
participé avec nous à ce qu'on appelle
l'intervention avant le prêche du
vendredi et il était là pour échanger
avec les musulmans qui ont été très
contents de le sentir avec eux donc je
pense c'est pareil démarche qui mérite
d'être salué en pareil moment pareil
moment de crise moment de tension et
nous avons bien sûr des relations avec
la communauté israélite de Versailles
j'ai même été appelé par le rabbin
Edmond beldub qui était ici et qui est
rentré donc euh à Jérusalem et donc nous
avons des échanges et on sait
parfaitement apprécier l'événement à sa
juste valeur sans que nous accusions des
défections au niveau des rangs et nous
participons c'est-à-dire dans ce dans
cette logique dans cette manière de de
réceptionner si on peut s'exprimer ainsi
le le drame de sorte que l'unité ne
n'empatisse pas et que on désavoue ce
qui qui avait l'intention de diviser al
l' unité c'est c'est important je me
tourne vers avibo vous êtes le président
du groupe interreligieux pour la paix
auquel appartient monsieur keroubi et
d'autres aussi c'est quoi l' près parce
que là on est dans les dans les
réactions pour l'instantanné c'est quoi
la près est-ce que c'est c'est
effectivement important à la fois
d'avoir ce dialogue interreligieux à la
fois d'avoir ce principe aussi
d'éducation dont dont vous
parliez notre rôle notre vocation groupe
interrégux pour la paix c'est de créer
c'est de maintenir des liens entre les
communautés localement à versaill la
paix qui nous intéresse c'est la paix
local donc dans une situation comme
celle-là les liens qui préexistaient
sont évidemment capitaux di samedi
dimanche nous sommes
partis nous sommes partis ensemble juifs
chrétiens et musulmans pour participer à
la manifestation on était un groupe
d'une 40 50 et il nous paraissait
important d'y aller ensemble parce que
ça avait du sens sinon il allait chacun
de notre côté euh c'était autre chose
mais là on s'est retrouvé ensemble alors
l'près c'est une question
capitale le dans cet attentat aussitôt
pour moi ça a été la crainte de d'un
éclatement d'une division de la société
française le dimanche ça été au
contraire au contraire la manifestation
d'une solidarité d'un rassemblement
extraordinaire quand on était sur place
voir cette marée humaine
d'allantp monre épaule d'un mur à
l'autre d'une grande avenue c'était
vraiment magnifique alors maintenant
cette solidarité est à maintenir et
c'est c'est bah c'est tout le toute la
la
difficulté au fil des
jours notre idée c'est qu'il faut que
les gens se connaissent se connaissent
et s'apprécient s'estiment euh c'est
pour ça que le groupe interreligieux
essae de créer des relations
personnelles pas seulement connaître
connaître la civilisation de l'autre pas
seulement connaître la religion de
l'autre c'est déjà très bien et ça
éveille la curiosité mais connaître
l'autre en tant que personne avoir des
amis des amis juifs des amis musulmans
ça c'est capital je je parlais aussi
d'éducation parce que je pense que c'est
c'est très très important aussi parce
que l'islam je tourne vers vous c'est
c'est assez vaste et toutes les tous les
musulmans se retrouvent pas forcément
dans les valeurs de de de vous qui êtes
un imam ou d'une association de
musulmans on a appris notamment que les
ferkashis par exemple avaient une
culture religieuse assez fragile en tout
cas le le mot a été présenté comme ça
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire à votre
avis pour aller justement vers ces
jeunes alors à la fois les jeunes qui
viennent à la mosquée mais il y a aussi
tous les jeunes qui ne viennent pas à la
mosquée qui peuvent être tenté d'un
départ vers le djihad si je peux me
permettre rajouter un point par rapport
à euh ce qui vient d'être dit c'est en
fait dans le cadre de ce vivre ensemble
je pense que le dialogue interreligieux
est une chose et fait je pense que la la
la ville de plaisir sur la ville de
plaisir depinavant on a on a ce dialogue
interreligieux avec les chrétiens mais
en même temps qui qui a
évolué selon les années on entretient en
fait des actions ensemble euh vis-à-vis
de la société on fait tous les ans des
collectes alimentaires et là ça permet
de de de de motiver tout le monde et
éventuellement les la communauté
musulmane la communauté chrétienne les
jeunes les moins jeunes pour venir euh
en aide au enfin aux gens défavorisés je
pense que c'est c'est c'est c'est très
important aussi que les musulmans
s'ouvrent vers l'extérieur donc la
mosquée de plaisir a été pour de années
consécutives
euh à organisé les portes ouvertes dans
les dans le cadre des journées du
patrimoine pour s'ouvrir et dire voilà
nous sommes là nous sommes des musulmans
venez découvrir ce qu'est l'islam même
si vous participez pas participez pas au
dialogue on est là par par rapport à la
question de l'éducation donc je pense
c'est le rôle et des parents d'une part
et également par rapport à
l'enseignement religieux des imams des
imams de France l'islam est une religion
du juste milieu l'islam modéré je pense
que la problématique aujourd'hui c'est
que il y a aussi les médias il y a
internet et on peut pas gérer tout le
monde aujourd'hui il y a des gens qui se
radicalisent parce que il consultent des
des des des sites jihadistes donc il y a
aussi la part euh aussi des
renseignements généraux sur ce genre de
point si on veut parler sur le point
d'éducation les principes de l'Islam qui
sont des principes humanistes
humanitaires de paix de miséricorde sont
clair je pense que ouvrir le dialogue
avec avec ces jeunes-là et leur montrer
avec le dialogue et avec les texte avec
l'échange que la violence n'a jamais été
et vous par exemple vous allez sur le
à plaisir parce que c'est votre la ville
où vous êtes imam je je à la rencontre
de ces jeunes qui viendraient pas
forcément à la mosquée et qui pourraient
être tenté on on le fait de temps en
temps mais effectivement ENF avec avec
avec avec toutes les responsabilités on
est capable d'aller ver mais en fait ce
qu'on ce qu'on fait réellement c'est les
gens qui fréquentent la mosquée de
manière régulière ou au moment des fêtes
religieuse où là tout le monde viit la
mosquée c'est là on essaie de faire
passer des les messages forts et dire
ceux qui sont présents qu'il
transmettent euh pour nous sur la ville
de Plaisir euh avant que la mosquée soit
installée qui est installé aujourd'hui
au valibau il y a eu chaque année euh à
la saintsylvestre des véhicules brûlés
les la première année euh nous avons euh
mis l'accent euh pendant les serments
pendant les conférences sur que le
musulman ne doit pas casser ne doit pas
brûler nous avons eu la félicitation de
au lendemain du réveil du réveillon euh
de la mairie par rapport qu'il y a eu
zéro voitures
brûlées sur sur la ville de plaisir au
valibau donc je pense que c'est de la
formation du dialogue et également bah
aussi les parents parce que je pense
qu'ussi les parents ont une grande
responsabilité vis-à-vis de leur leur
leur leurs enfants il y a un point
essentiel aussi c'est le point de de de
de de de laastigmatisation je suis pas
enfin on peut pas justifier
l'injustifiable de de de de commettre un
crime ou une réaction violente au nom
d'une religion ou sous des prétextes non
mais je pense
que j'aimerais bien compter sur on va
dire le la clairevoyance de nos
concitoyens pour reconsidérer leur je
parle pas de la majorité une partie de
reconsidérer leur vision des musulmans
de France c'est des musulmans c'est des
Français sont nés en France grandis en
France ils ont leurs mots à apporter à
la société malheureusement ce qu'on voit
dans les plateaux télévision c'est qu'on
demande aux musulmans de se justifier
par rapport à ce que font certains
musulmans mais au moins d'expliquer
parce que voilà on on pose rarement la
question
dites-nous qu'est-ce que propose l'Islam
pour le vivre ensemble pour améliorer
cette cette société la France je l'aime
mais je l'améliore m je vis vous faire
réagir sur la question de de de
l'éducation c'est
essentiel bien sûr tout à fait c'est
essentiel et c'est essentiel partout
c'est-à-dire
que aujourd'hui en France il y a une
grande il y a une jeunesse euh qui est
énorme qui grandit et qui qui est
présente et à et à nous à notre société
d'apporter cette éducation de leur
montrer de leur apprendre justement se
vivre ensemble de leur apprendre que les
différences c'est ce qui forme la
richesse de la France et dans cette
France dans laquelle on vit justement où
on aime se voir se connaître chacun en
étant
différent sans provoquer quiconque et
quoi que ce soit c'est nous vivons
ensemble parce que nous devons vivre
ensemble parce que nous avons le plaisir
de vivre ensemble tout en étant
différent mais ça ne fait ça ne fait pas
ça ne gêne personne vous avez parlé du
dialogue interreligieux mais il existe
depuis un petit moment ce dialogue inter
releligieux on se rappelle notamment
d'un événement c'était l'incendie de la
synagogue de trap c'était en 2001 et à
partir de ce moment-là c'est vrai que
les communautés religieuses se sont mis
à se parler ensemble quel bilan on peut
tirer je me tourne vers vous vous avez
gros de de ce dialogue inter
religieux difficile de tirer un bilan
c'est difficile de euh parce que 14 ans
après on voit les images là de la
synagogue en 2001 qui avait brûlé à
trappe 14 ans après le dialogue il est
toujours
d'actualité on dit il faut toujours
parler faut toujours parler je dirais
c'est pas les événements dramatiques qui
justifient enfin qui justifient le
dialogue sil y avait si tout allait bien
il faudrait d'autant plus ferait aussi
dialoguer il faudrait aller vers l'autre
mon voisin parlait tout à l'heure de
clairvoyant il demander la clairvoyance
de des autres citoyens vis-à-vis
de de des Français des musulmans de
France des Français musulmans moi je
dirais même
bienveillance on a un un regard méfiant
on a un regard bienveillant vis-à-vis de
celui qui est en face de vous de de son
voisin n'importe quel voisin de de celui
qu'on rencontre le regard méfiant tout
de suite ça traduit et ça bloque toute
rencontre le regard bienveillant c'est
le regard qui permet de comprendre
l'autre d'accepter l'autre de savoir de
lui poser des questions de savoir ce
qu'il pense et d'essayer de se mettre à
sa place pour voir comment il réagit
comprendre ses réactions puis petit à
petit lorsque l'estime vient entre les
deux faire comprendre nos réactions à
nous aussi donc il faut continuer ce
dialogue inter inter donc le dialogue
interreligieux moi je dirais le dialogue
entre communautés entre interculturel
interreligieux interreligieux ça limite
un peu les choses mais je il faut se
rencontrer H qu'est-ce que vous voudriez
demander aux politiques aujourd'hui
parce que la question elle est
effectivement de de une question
d'éducation une question de
d'explication de de de l'islam et c'est
aussi peut-être une question de
politique de choix politique on
demanderait l'émancipation j'allais dire
naturelle de ce dialogue interreligieux
puisque vous avez parler de trappe euh
et bien oui un exemple un exemple au
lycée un des lycées de trappe nous avons
été conviés il y avait le vice l'ancien
président Sam Moison moi-même il y avait
le prêtre de trappe et ensite ensite il
y avait donc un professeur d'éducation
nationale qui s'était déclaré at et il y
avait donc cette rencontre ce débat
interreligieux à l'intérieur de de du
lycée ça permet à à ces jeunes
adolescents en quête de de devenir en
futur citoyen d'apprécier la qualité du
du du dialogue et de savoir que cela
existe et donc ça ça crée en eux un
référentiel donc l'expérience se
reproduite deux fois il y a eu ilons
jeis dire un engouement de la part des
élèves à ce que ça se reprodu sauf que
tout de suite l'école au nom de la
laïcité c'est refermé et c'est interdit
c'est interdit de permettre à ces
citoyens de qui sont dans la cité et
ensuite c'est un modèle hein c'est une
modèlisation jeux dire qui qui pouvait
on pouvait être exigeant au niveau de
cette de pareil à manifestation peut
augmenter mettre un cahier des charges
et être exigeent mais je pense que ça a
été la droit de de de l'interrompre au
vu de la demande et au vu du besoin mais
là est-ce que ça va est-ce que ça va pas
reprendre au vu des événements qui
tragiques qui son son je l'espère du
moins vous avez parlé vous avez dit tous
les musulmans sont voilà se
reconnaissent au travers de du prêche
d'un imam modéré et
ceteraoui vous avez pas tous mais le pas
tous il est un peu gros parce que si on
prend les les gens qui ont perpétré par
exemple cet attentat je j'ai écouté hier
à la télévision je crois BFM TV où euh
le le le mentor de de ces de ces deux
jeunes monsieur Farid benénitou si je me
si je me trompe pas avait dit qu'il les
avait rencontrés il y a 2 mois et que
comment il dresse il dit c'est un homme
de très peu de religion quand on lui
parlait de Dieu ça ne l'intéressait pas
ce qui l'intéressait c'est plutôt le
combat donc j'allais dire le Prophète de
l'Islam comme il a dit lorsqu'il était
ce qu'on appelle la la la l'année de la
tristesse quand il a perdu sa femme et
son oncle quand il était le les les la
première poignée de musulmans quand ils
étaient en quarantaine il décida d'aller
à Taif taf étant une ville à proximité
de laamrique une quarantaine de kilomè
et il s'est fait caillacer et son sang a
coulé et dans le réc on raconte que deux
anges vientent lui dit un mot de toi et
Dieu ordonne l'extermination de ces
gens-là et le Prophète il dit oh Dieu si
euh tu n'es pas en colère contre moi euh
je te demande de pardonner à mon peuple
car il ne sait pas donc voilà le
prophète qui a fait couler son sang
voilà le voilant par donnant donc voilà
la la disproportion l'incompréhension
enfin disons le il y a des gens qui ne
connaissent pas la religion et ne
cherchent pas à la connaître on on les a
plutôt
traîné ensuite il faut
êtreou ensuite il faut être pragmatique
parce qu'il faut regarder aussi cet
événement il faut lui donner il faut
l'analyser hein il y a les journalistes
qui se prent il y a des analyses
concernant justement ce drame de quoi de
quoi il est composé donc il y a pas que
la question religieuse il y a la
question de
laque Mad dis pardon qu'est-ce que vous
voudriez demander aux
politiques alors parce qu'on sait que la
question est politique aussi tout à fait
alors bon déjà on peut voir que la
politique a très bien réagi tout de
suite bien sur sur les sur l'émotion on
va dire pour revenir sur cette marche
qui montrait justement que la France est
bien vivante et dans cette solidarité
dans cette unité la France l'Europe et
quatre des cinq continents mondiaux
représentés tout à fait donc on est on
est bien là et on peut bien vivre
ensemble justement c'est pouvoir le
continuer pvoir le perpétuer que ça
puisse continuer que ce soit dans les
établissements scolaires que ça soit
ailleurs ça so dans notre jeunesse on
parlait d'éducation mais c'est justement
qu'on puisse continuer que ça ne reste
pas à cause d'un événement dramatique
qui a pu se produire mais que ça reste
dans notre vie donc on continuit à à
donner à donner à donner la parole à
expliquer aux générations qu'elles soi
jeune ouou ou moins jeune merci à vous
quatre d'être venu sur le le plateau
téléf dans sur cette suite société pour
donner un éclairage on aurait pu parler
encore plus plus longuement merci
beaucoup en tout cas à vous quatre cette
émission est terminée merci de l'avoir
suivi je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée